this is the story of the Lockheed SR71
Blackbird the Invincible spy plane that
can only be described as a miracle of
engineering capable of cruising 16 miles
above the surface of the Earth at more
than three times the speed of sound the
SR71 was the perfect spy play it was one
of the first built with a stealth design
that dramatically reduced its radar
signature an estimated 4 thousands
surface to a missiles were fired at the
SR71 not a single one hit its
Mark for almost 30 years the SR71 ruled
the skies an Untouchable Phantom that
would occasionally coales on enemy
Radars before disappearing into the EPA
to this day the SR71 Remains the fastest
air breathing airplane ever
built